[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité un
adolescent retrouvé pendu dans sa
chambre hier à Poissy le jeune de 15 ans
est décédé malgré l'intervention des
pompiers au domicile familial dans le
quartier de La Maladrerie selon nos
confrères du Parisien les enquêteurs du
commissariat de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
privilégie la thèse du suicide en lien
avec des faits de harcèlement scolaire
dont été victimes le garçon dans son
ancien lycée Adrienne Bolland à Poissy
il avait signalé ses faits avec son père
il y a quelques mois au commissariat de
police de la ville l'adolescent avait
été rescolarisé dans un lycée de Paris à
la rentrée
les Jeux Olympiques à Paris est dans les
Yvelines c'est dans 324 jours cette
semaine le comité d'organisation reçoit
les médias du monde entier pour les
préparer à l'événement où vont
travailler 4000 journalistes et 1500
photographes au programme notamment de
cette semaine la visite des différencie
des JO c'est ici aux alentours de 13h
que 400 à journalistes internationaux
sont arrivés ici dans les Yvelines au
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour découvrir
les lieux qui vont les épreuves de
cyclisme sur pistes lors des Jeux
olympiques de Paris à 2024 ils se sont
ensuite rendus du côté du Stadium de BMX
un lieu qui va accueillir les épreuves
de BMX Race ensuite tout le monde a
embarqué pour rejoindre le château de
Versailles un lieu qui va accueillir à
la fois les épreuves d'équitation et de
pentathlon moderne ils se sont ensuite
tous rendus à Paris pour visiter à les
sites parisiens qui ont accueillir à les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques en 2024
hier les journalistes ont participé à
une journée à briefing dans un hôtel
parisien ils ont pu poser toutes leurs
questions concernant leur accréditation
ou encore le matériel qu'ils pourront
utiliser sur place au total 4000
journalistes seront à qualité pour
l'événement et ils viendront du monde
entier et à quelques jours des
traditionnelles forums des associations
Voisins-le-Bretonneux lancent cette
initiative à 100 minutes le principe
dédié environ une minute de vidéo
associations pour qu'elles puissent se
faire connaître et être valorisé ses
capsules sont ensuite diffusées sur les
réseaux sociaux et le site Internet de
la Ville l'ensemble des 140 associations
vicinoises peu en bénéficier il suffit
de prendre contact avec la mairie